Geneva's car show is a carnival for the
automobile there are lots of new models
here and some that are vintage minis
have been around for 60 years
they are now made by BMW in this Factory
in Cowley four and a half thousand
people work here but today the German
company told Sky News that a No Deal
brexit would raise questions over this
factory's future this would be really a
huge burden off of a mini brand you know
and if this would come which is the
worst case scenario you're just
mentioning now we would need to consider
what it exactly means for us on the long
run and for me this is really a danger
no doubt about does that mean
effectively moving many else it would be
an option moving many out of the UK we
at least have to consider you know
because we cannot absorb 10% costs on
top of it the mini plant is already
scheduled to close for a week after
March the 29th to cope with any
disruption so what happens to that plan
if the date for brexit is pushed back we
cannot this is done we will need to
close it anyway so yeah for us of course
you know it's delaying depends a little
bit of now how but delay is you know if
it's a 2 3 months delay which would be
not we would not be very happy because
we need certainty in our plan premises
you know and and this is not happening
right now this isn't just about BMW or
putting pressure on politicians I've
spoken to a range of car company bosses
here in Geneva and without exception
they've all said that they're worried
about brexit and the impact it could
have on the UK car industry French
company PSA owned Peugeot and voxel they
fear and no do brexit will lead to
higher prices so the price of the cars
are you kid
we'll be a far above what they are today
and so leading to an decrease of the UK
market which will be once again
impactful but many believe this is all
just scare mongering it's a claim I put
to the boss of Aston Martin
none of the car companies will turn it
off overnight because there's big
investments to make platforms in United
Kingdom factories but over a period of
time as they sure as the car companies
change over to the new cars those cars
will not come to the United Kingdom it's
nothing to do with fear it's everything
to do with reality brexit is the most
immediate worry but the car industry is
planning for a future shaped by many
other challenges there's some real real
concerns across all manufacturers but
it's one to be honest with you amongst
many I mean electrification co2 is also
big concern for manufacturers as well as
how do we meet those and at the same
time how do we make electric vehicles
accessible to many but electric cars
will take decades to perfect brexit is
imminent and its effects on this
industry are now resonating Adam Parsons
Sky News Geneva